voici julien lepers
c'est bon
julien lepers
alors voilà je viens lepers y voir une
nouvelle rubrique dans cette émission
oui qui s'appellera la question de
julien légendaire quelques-unes pour toi
voilà et la victime sera michel larocque
et voilà mais d'abord on va parler un
petit peu de vous
alors je vais faire comme vous l'avez
que la fiche de rien comme ça comme
optic 2000
alors non non non j'ai fait ça au début
du moi j'aime bien julien lepers et date
de la première émission de questions
pour un champion en 88
bravo 88 9 ans 81,8 ça va faire un jour
le jour le jour je veux le jour annonce
je sais pas je ne sais pas novembre
novembre le jour mais j'ai pas le 7
novembre par le set
ouais ça à faire 13 ans et oui t'as pas
bien s'est campé le décor parce que je
viens et c'est un truc très bien ce que
les champs et beaucoup de personnes
âgées qui le regarde et lui y situe bien
ai dit vous êtes chez vous il est 19h 45
vous êtes chez vous regardez françois
bon ça rassure les personnages à vue
et quand un prix trop de mecs 2007 le
jihad contre mettre en situation bien
alors quelques jours suivants la
question suivante julien lepers
combien de candidats avez vous déjà reçu
tu m'as fait peur alors là vous verrez
5000 5,6 me c'est ça non exactement
julien lepers combien de question avez
vous posé à vos candidats alors la gérer
400000 nom n'a pas dit le salaire 350
oui oui je t'écoute
je viens de perdre combien le
téléspectateur avez vous chaque soir
non ça ça dépend ça sert un qui meurt
beaucoup
moi je suis sur le numéro à tous les
soirs oui à cette heure là je m'endors
de leurs 18h20 18h53 moi et mes oreilles
de combien l'été 2 millions l'hiver
quatre mois la millions julien lepers
quelle est votre part de marché se
dépenser variable mais je dirais 35 40 %
c'est ça
messieurs si vous regardez les questions
pour un champion
moi je regarde mais surtout mon épouse
ouais mais elle est pas trop page et
comme dirait ma fille oui oui votre
famille dans le dernier roman de michel
houellebecq qui s'appelle plateforme le
héros passe son temps à regarder
questions pour un champion pas ça mais
c'était sur la thaïlande avec les
masseuses il ya des [ __ ] en thaïlande
il ya aussi le mec avant de lentilles
landi regarde quelle souffrance champion
de singe tentent de fuir la france son
attention encore une question julien
lepers quel est le secret de ce succès
ne dis pas que c'est l'animateur non non
non non c'est l'europe qui l'a dit c'est
pas moi non c'est un mélange est un bien
beau travail d'équipé
il ya chez pas je m'adresse à tous le
mondial et les personnes âgées bien sûr
et les jeunes et très jeunes ont fait
des juniors ont fait des gens connus ont
fait pour ta vie tu seras peut-être
laurent jour si tu es d'accord et que
tirer aussi enfin je sais qu elle aussi
michèle et michel l'a déjà fait cette
émission c'est vrai et à la ville ça
fout les jetons n'ont pas la réponse
avant mais non mais c'est quel chanteur
américain doit-on l'album toi qu'est
l'île volcanique de la méditerranée est
également baptisé terreur du grec
signifiant la bête sauvage santorin
ouais bravo
quand je lui ai une autre par la route
principe moral appelé à ims a en hindi
j'impose une grande maîtrise de soi
respect de toute personne même de son
adversaire érigée en principe d'action
politique au xxème siècle mise en oeuvre
dans des luttes pour l'indépendance j'ai
inspiré des actions une grève de la faim
la non-violence bravo
mais quand tu nous a demandé qu'on ils
ont répété tout non pas du tout gardez
vous en faites sur la musique / musique
music chanteur décédé en 84 4 après 2,7
choisi ling et ouais je lis les trois
autres juste comme ça hein
quel chanteur noir américaines et ont 28
et le créateur de sex machine en 70 sur
lui à la fois tout est fouillé qui
interprète qui interprète qui à tapas
tutti frutti ouais je vois qu alors là
c'est beaucoup plus dur
je dis si vous avez la réponse à vous
êtes fort chez vous ça vous fait quoi
rome est latent depuis 1957 oui quel
chanteur 57 la date et le chanteur
interprète la chanson qui la dernière
chanson du titre chanson titre du film
island in the sun arriver là
le mieux armé
tu sais pourquoi annoncer pour vous
c'est merci jouer on se rend compte à
quel point cette émission est
intéressante elle en évolution c'est
monsieur tout le monde est vraiment
concentré et la mort il faut dire
effectivement la vérité c'est que vous
auriez préféré animer une émission
musicale c'est vrai c'est vrai votre
père était chef d'orchestre il est
toujours là jouer il a joué sur jules
maire georges ulmer paul anka en langue
accompagner leurs caisses de pommery
l'aï dirigé leurs caisses de banca
pianiste à l'époque de diana diana à
l'époque de boutures head and shoulders
tu vois la grande époque et georges
henner vous connaissez aujourd'hui le
maire michel serrault
à l'époque jean julien était très grand
et votre mère et votre mère était
chanteuse sous le nom de maria rémusat
réexaminerait mézin vous êtes un
pianiste émérite projecteurs en fédérant
entendu vous avez julien lepers avait
écrit pour michel delpech vous écris
pour sheila sylvie vartan et vous avez
surtout écrit ça
alors
oh
gc
oui
ah ah
là
je lui appartenait
m
or non seulement julien lepers mais
l'émission culte mais il a écrit une
chanson qui fait partie des cinquante
chansons préférées des français
g séries millions d'exemplaires vendus
voilà en fait la vérité c'est que vous
étiez antibes et vous avez passé un
concours d'animateur pour elle c'est
vrai c'est comme ça que vous êtes devenu
animateur radio à la d'abord ensuite
france 2 oui antenne 2 voilà ensuite
ensuite rtl ensuite way et puis d'autres
émissions de télé moi je sais pas là on
a fait plein voilà et lorsqu'il faut
dire aussi puisque l'on dit ou ce soir
vous n'êtes pas le frère de john paul
lepers non c'est un journaliste je n'ai
jamais vu un excellent journaliste mais
dans batman je suis le frère de michael
pitt michael keaton est venu n'ya pas
longtemps à nice il est resté deux mois
à nice pour jouer avec judith godrèche
il a faim oui c'est ça exactement tout
le monde l'a arrêté dans la rue un bien
soirée julien docteur julien le faire ça
on voit de temps en temps je vais aux
états unis hammerson j'allais je me
souviens il ya un arrêt des combats la
rue mais tout le monde doit demander des
autographes de michael keaton jacques
michael keaton la wii d'autographes s'il
vous plaît est maintenant bien bon alors
julien ce qu'il faut dire aussi parce
qu'on se dit tous vraiment ce soir un
nazi c'est que julien c'est pas votre
vrai prénom
non c'est vrai mais il n'y a pas de
problème je suis à l'aise en lambeaux
web et noir c'est vraiment au nom héros
n a donc on va faire une interview
prénom la bouche
ça va pas du tout va aller baptiste
alors faire une interview prénom ouais
je vais vous donner des noms et vous
allez me dire le prénom vas-y voilà ce
héros michèle laroque échelle baffie
jorge luis evelyne très bien onasis chez
aristote pinochet [ __ ] travers
dans sa gestion et sa longue houle gusto
au coup sûr oui bien sûr pavarotti
luciano bien miossec cdu christophe
bravo c'était un peu souffler le
soufflage et à perdre âge commence bien
le capitaine dreyfus
alfred bravo diderot denis bravo the de
melk chop up your avons vraiment l on
continue avec une marque lacoste pas de
marc rene oui du bellay joachim bravo
mallarmé chez fans
bravo zannini marcel niarcos stravius
previous thé view sera comme ça par
l'ouest à vous ce week end aux membres
en région mais la réponse est refusé
pourquoi un retard apple dip ils sont
bien mais il faut dire une chose il faut
dire la vérité et michel j'ai vu le même
numéro et qu'ils étaient à médrano il ya
15 ans j'en ai deux petites séries vas-y
vas-y a valu une petite série parce
qu'on se marre
donnant bien bon allez oui tu fais le
chanteur interprète douala et ces voix
là c'est charles arrête un joli quel
groupe interprète papa temptation très
bien quel chanteur et guitariste
interprète reggio 69 et jimi hendrix
ça c'est fait ça oui à quel chanteur de
ton album thriller thriller taken
hackett chanteur qui est chanteur
guitariste interprète on broadway green
knight gilden way jalil à bananes vous
voilà on arrête là parce que y'en a de
musique ça pourrait faire une émission
je sais pas si ce sont les patrons
flamands judiciaire alors celle là à
l'essai la tient au jurassique qu'elle
dinosaure herbivore du groupe des sceaux
reste y possédait un coût et une queue
allongé - velociraptor terrassé rock
terrade en tiens ça commence par un dc10
petit pécule diplodocus web un constat
bien
d'accord mais messieurs pour la première
fois de la saison la question 2 julien
lepers hors jeu bien sûr julien si vous
voulez bien vous mettre là bah ouais la
question du lien à le faire sera posée
régulièrement à tous les invités
oui tout à fait là vous n'êtes que la
première victime michel larocque rature
attention attention
avoue julien depuis septembre 2001 et
même plus avant quelle explication
peut-on donner à la phrase suivante et
danser à plusieurs reprises dans
l'émission tout le monde en parle on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle michel pour
contrarier baffie si votre dernier mot
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne doit pas bouger
par le jingle
je pense que s'achevait pas et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus